[Music]
hello my name is Kent Mullenix I am the
director of the Institute for
sustainable food systems at Kwantlen
Polytechnic University the Institute is
an applied research and extension unit
at the University focused exclusively on
small-scale regenerative community
focused agriculture and farming systems
it's a pleasure to be here with you and
to share my experiences and thinking
about extension and the potential of
extension services to serve BC's
agriculture and food system sector as I
know you are aware agriculture in our
food system faces many sustainability
challenges as we move into the 21st
century and it now and acknowledge that
sustainability is our supreme challenge
not the least of which and that
challenge is adapting to and mitigating
climate change and there's a great deal
of interest in applied research and
extension however there is a great deal
of uncertainty and and lack of clarity
around what extension is and what it can
do and that's the objective of our
webinar today we're going to discuss
agriculture extension and how it
operates and how it can serve VC's
agriculture and food systems sector
going forward so the objective of
tonight's presentation is to clarify and
convey the power and the potential and
the necessity of agricultural extension
I hope to bring clarity to what
extension is how its configured and how
it can operate effectively who can and
should
deliver extension programming and
finally how extension can advance
climate change mitigation and adaptation
so the place to begin I think is to
discuss what extension is it is
practiced around the world and there is
no universally accepted definition of
extension its variably adapted to places
and challenges but regardless it is
constructed around us a central
methodology a widely accepted central
construct certainly extension can focus
on many different social and economic
elements for example there can be youth
development extension economic
development extension community
extension home horticulture extension so
any dimension of social or economic
development can be the focus of
extension programming probably
agricultural extension is the oldest and
best developed extension focus and
that's what we're going to focus on in
our discussions today Agricultural
Extension so agricultural extension is
the application of new knowledge that is
derived from applied scientific research
to agricultural practices through farmer
engagement and education programming
it's a pretty simple and straightforward
concept the purpose of agricultural
extension of any extension for that
matter is to transfer new knowledge and
facilitate its adoption by the sector in
our case agriculture in the food system
to affect change
and improvement it can focus on any
aspect of agriculture agriculture
mechanization rural sociology pest
management soils and fertility
management agricultural economics farm
business planning and and business
management to name a few
regardless of its focus Agricultural
Extension is inextricably linked to
Applied Research leading to knowledge
creation method creation or tool
creation so the important message here
is that it's about new knowledge
transferring that knowledge to the folks
that will use it and effecting change in
the sector extension also constitutes a
very effective communication conduit
between researchers and farmers or those
who are going to use the new knowledge
the methods or tools it's important to
emphasize that this communication
conduit is is a two-way mechanism and is
ongoing so farmers communicating to
researchers researchers communicating to
farmers and envision a busy two-way
street with cars going back and forth
constantly that's what the kind of
communication what extension facilitates
that kind of communication is absolutely
predicated on effective relationships
and we're going to talk more about
relationships cooperation is also key to
effective extension service delivery in
fact I'd say it's essential there must
be cooperation between farmers and
extension professionals and researchers
and it's that cooperation that supports
the whole extension knowledge
mobilization
and sector change in the u.s.
cooperation is exhibited between three
levels of government the federal
government the state government and
county government or local government
and land-grant universities that are
located in each state of the United
States and we'll talk about this model a
little bit going forward but we'll leave
it there for now but suffice it to say
because of this high level of
cooperation between farmers extension
personnel and researchers and between
levels of government and land-grant
university colleges of Agriculture in
the u.s. Agricultural Extension is
called cooperative the Cooperative
Extension Service ultimately I think
extension functions as the fulcrum and
cement for sector advancement and change
in this partnership and this high level
of cooperation and I think this is an
important thing to note because many of
the challenges that agriculture and our
food system face today and will face
going into the 21st century to become
more sustainable like climate change
adaptation and mitigation are highly
complex problems that involve multiple
actors and have many moving parts and
take a great deal of effort to
effectively address and so it's
extension that can facilitate that it's
extension in my estimation that can
effectively bring all of that together
and keep it all together and and make
change happen more effectively so
ultimately a extension effective
agricultural extension is predicated on
relationships and I want to emphasize
this and it's not just
casual relationship it's a very deep
functional relationship I describe it as
genuine mutually respectable very
durable and and and a roll up the
sleeves make it happen kind of
relationship and and really researchers
and farmers and extension personnel
function as a close knit team so
extension creates a team mentality
[Music]